. Ja, wir sind Stefan Tatze und Florentin Woll. Jo, schön, dass ihr da seid, herzlich willkommen. Wir begrüssen euch ganz herzlich in unserer kleinen warmen Butze. Habe ich viele gute Nachrichten bekommen zu Stefan Tatze, meinem Bären in Dota 2, seitdem leider jedes Spiel verloren. Haha, kein Problem, macht ja nichts. Aber das ist ja vorher auch jedes Spiel verloren. Das stimmt. Das ist ja wie bei mir beim Schach, irgendwann habe ich ja die Karriere an Nagel gehängt. Das ist ja so eine Art Spiel, wo man es auch sehr schwer auf andere schieben kann und der selbst, also stell es mir vor, ich weiß es nicht so wahnsinnig wie bei Dota,
aber man hasst sich schon sehr doll danach, oder?
Ja, absolut. Aber es ist auch ein Teamspiel,
das heißt, man hasst seine Teamgefährten auch sehr.
Man schreit, man hat Mikrofone,
man redet mit Leuten auf der anderen Seite der Welt.
Eigentlich wunderbar, man könnte sich verbinden
über Sprachgrenzen hinweg.
Aber nein, man schreit sich an und es ist ganz furchtbar.
Flamend sich, wie man in der Gamersprache sagt.
Und da hat einer gesagt, einer hat wirklich zu mir gesagt,
I wish you die.
Und dann habe ich gesagt,
that's such a rude thing to say,
you say that because of a video game?
Hast du wirklich gesagt?
Habe ich gesagt, alles on stream?
Nicht im Stream, aber privat, und er meinte,
yeah, you're right, I'm sorry.
Woher kam der? So ein kurzer Moment, weiss ich nicht, so ein kurzer Moment, ja, you're right, I'm sorry. Woher kam der?
So ein kurzer Moment, weiss ich nicht,
so ein kurzer Moment, wo er wirklich, ah, I'm sorry.
Wo ich wirklich war, weil das Ding ist, das passiert nie.
Dota ist so extrem toxisch.
Wenn jemand toxisch ist, dann übersteigen sich die
und beleidigen sich noch mehr.
Es ist ganz selten, dass jemand mal sagt,
that's such a rude thing to say.
I hope you die.
Is it a video game? Und er sagt dann wirklich, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. Aber wie oft hast du dann so toxisch rumgeflampt? Ich habe ja, ich glaube meine wirklich nicht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Florentin spricht zu uns. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich sage das nicht den anderen, ich bin schon, ich bin, ich richte meine Wut in mich selbst und ich hasse mich dann selber und ich haue dann auf den Tisch und so und Wut und ich weiß nicht, ob das die bessere Strategie ist, weil ich habe das Gefühl, die anderen, die das nach außen strahlen, die sind halt sauer, die beleidigen, aber die können dann gut weiterspielen, ich bin nicht die ganze Woche sauer. So ein Ventil. Ich bin die ganze Woche sauer. Ich bin zwar höflicher vielleicht, aber ich bin halt dann am Ende selber der Trottel, der alles
abkriegt. Und ich richte das eher an mich selber und ich versuche immer, der Devote zu sein. Wenn der mich flamst, sage ich, ja, I'm sorry, I apologize, you're right, okay, let's focus on the next play, let's focus on the next play. Ich versuche immer, mich hinzulegen, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das klappt oder ob das Leute noch wütender macht, aber es ist wirklich, ich bin sofort beim Entschuldigen. Ja, weil dann bist du wie ein Boxsack. Ja doch,
weiß ich nicht genau. Also die Boxsack-Metapher
ist natürlich insofern passend, weil man
Energie rauslässt und so an etwas.
Ja. Man hat ein Ventil für sich selber,
aber wenn du
sozusagen so ein Ziel für die bist, auf das sie
draufpanschen wollen und du ergibst dich sofort
und sagst, nein, nein, nein, weiße Flaggen
und dann legst du dich sozusagen
auf den Bauch.
Weiß nicht, ob das so, ob das dann
den Zweck verfehlt. Ich analysiere das oft so
Aber fort und sagst, nein, nein, nein, weisse Flaggen und dann legst du dich sozusagen auf den Bauch.
Weiß nicht, ob das so oft, dass dann der Zweck verfehlt. Ich analysiere das oft so,
wie eskalieren solche Sachen, weil es ist oft,
einer ist toxisch und das kann man
oft nicht verhindern, so, der ist halt toxisch,
der ist halt jetzt gerade getriggert, der ist halt drauf.
Aber relevanter ist die
zweite Person. Wenn die zweite
Person auch toxisch ist und zurückschießt,
dann explodiert alles, weil dann
steigern die sich hoch, dann wird es immer schlimmer,
dann steigen die anderen ein. Aber bist du die ganze Zeit mit
Vielen Dank. zweite Person. Wenn die zweite Person auch toxisch ist und zurückschießt, dann explodiert alles. Weil dann steigern die sich hoch, dann wird es immer schlimmer, dann steigen die anderen ein. Aber bist du die ganze Zeit mit Fremden gepaart? Ja, ja. Also ich spiele auch mit Leuten, die ich kenne und so, auch aus meiner Gilde-Butter-Bande, kommt auf rochepit.de auf dem Discord. Aber ich versuche immer der Zweite zu sein, der sagt, ah, it's okay, it's fine, happens, just chill out, so.
Der versucht, weil dann wissen alle anderen im Team, au, es gibt, wir müssen jetzt gar nicht streiten, so, ist okay, passt schon. Wir haben auch einen, an dem wir uns hängen können, der einen Gegenpol gibt. Das ist so eine faszinierende Welt für mich. Und nicht dann alles explodieren müssen, so. Aber das Spiel ist ja, da legt es ja darauf an. Also fünf gegen fünf ist es ja, ne? Oft fremde Leute zu Paren gegen andere fünf Leute auf der Welt.
Jesus Christ.
Alle haben wahrscheinlich schon viel zu viele Stunden an dem Tag hinter sich.
Ja, und ich bin ja in ziemlich niedriger Rang.
Also das sind ja Leute, die spielen vielleicht schon seit 5000 Stunden,
haben aber einen total niedrigen Rang.
Alle, die Dota spielen, denken, sie hätten eigentlich einen höheren Rang verdient, aber das Team hält sie zurück. Sie verlieren die Spiele nur wegen den Teams. Das heißt, die sehen die Teams-Kameraden eigentlich nur als Hürde, als Ballast. Gibt es irgendeine Spielsportart, wo Leute sich schlechter einschätzen, als sie sind? Ist es nicht Sport? Minigolf vielleicht? Sport kompetitiv inhärent? Also ich habe beim Minigolf schon Schläge getroffen, wo ich dachte, den habe ich nicht verdient. Ich bin schlechter als das. Aber das passiert ja manchmal, weil die Banden, also dann wo soll der Ball auch hin? Ja, aber ich denke mir so, manchmal treffe ich und ich schließe so ein Minigolf-Spiel, aber ich denke mir, das war ich habe weit überperformed, also das ist nicht mein Niveau. So, hier sind eure Karten, dankeschön für die Schläge, ja, sie haben einen Bahnrekord gebrochen. Ich habe, wie will ich, ich habe einen Bahnrekord gebrochen? Ja, sie haben einen Bahnrekord gebrochen, also hier gibt es irgendwie eine, es kriegen wir eine Pizza und eine Cola aussuchen. Also können Sie Margarita, Sie können wählen zwischen Margarita, Tonno oder Salami. Das kann ich nicht annehmen, also das ist mein zweites Minigolfspiel, das war einfach alles. Aber ist es okay, wenn ich den Namen Namen ausschreibe? Auf gar keinen Fall, das geht nicht. Das ist weit über meinem Niveau. Ich habe einfach hier und da ein bisschen Glück gehabt. Da war ein Tannenzapfen auf der Golfbahn so, der Ball ist gegen den Tannenzapfen und dann ins Loch rein. Das war beeindruckend, das war noch niemand. Und er hat schon der Europameister gespielt. Das ist einfach, das ist komplettes Glück. Das kann ich nicht machen, das kann ich nicht annehmen. Mit dem 90 Prozent in einem Schlag geschafft. Ja, das war Zufall, das war scheut, da war es eine Taube, da dachte ich, okay, ich muss halt um die Taube rum und habe ich aus Versehen gegen die Bande und ins Loch. Das war alles aus Versehen. Dann hat mir den Bahnrekord gebrochen. Wisst ihr was, ich wollte immer so gut sein wie sie, ich habe das Minigolf-Laden, aber ich, sie haben mir gezeigt, dass es keinen Sinn mehr ergibt. Also ich bin falsch in diesem Job. Hier haben Sie den Schlüssel vom Vereinshaus, hier haben Sie den Meisterbrief. Das kann ich ... Das ist mein Minigolf, ich habe den Minigolf-Meister gemacht, war das das? 89 habe ich den gemacht? Wahnsinn. Ja genau, kurz vor dem Mauerfall. Hier haben Sie den Meisterbrief, dann schreibe ich auf Sie um. Ja, sonst Auto, ja, okay, habe ich alles dabei. Gut, dann packe ich es jetzt und dann, ja, viel Spaß mit dem Verein. Ja, so passiert das, ne? Es kann immer passieren. Du bist der Beste in einem Sport und dann kommt irgendein Amateur und besiegt dich einfach mal aus Zufall. Also ich interpretiere diesen Sketch anders.
Ja, okay. Was ist deine Interpretation? Meine Interpretation ist, das war eine Satire, eine Verballhornung der Tatsache, dass sich niemand unter, okay, ich sage nur, niemand hat sich jemals bei Sportarten unterscheidzt. So, und was ist jetzt richtig? Weil wir sind ja die Urheber dieses Sketches und wir haben beide unterschiedliche Interpretationen und Dinge, die wir damit aussagen wollten. Wenn jetzt das in ... Wie bei allen Dingen. Vielleicht ist beides richtig, vielleicht ist die Mitte. Vielleicht ist auch die Mitte besser als eines dieser Extreme. Vielleicht ist die Mitte, nämlich man sollte sich bei Sportarten realistisch einschätzen, der richtige Weg. Ich habe eine ganz faszinierende Szene letztens beobachtet. Und zwar war da ein kleines Mädchen mit da irgendwie Oma oder so, halt irgendwie wirklich großer Abstand. Und dann sagt das Mädchen, ich habe heute meine Lieblingshose an, da sind Erdbeeren drauf. Und dann schaut die Oma die Hose an und sagt, nein, das sind keine Erdbeeren, das sind nur rote Kreise. Und da dachte ich mir, das ist, das ist jetzt faszinierend, weil das Mädchen sieht Erdbeeren und sagt, das sind meine Erdbeerhose, meine Lieblingshose mit Erdbeeren. Ist das das neue The Dress? Ja, und die Oma sagt, das sind nur rote Kreise. Und dann dachte ich mir, man könnte hier wahrscheinlich jetzt ein komplettes Seminar über Symbolik und kulturelles Verständnis, Wahrnehmungsethik und was ist Kunst und wer entscheidet, weil wer sagt denn, dass das keine Erdbeeren sind? Weil du kannst ja eine Frucht. Sind nicht abstrakte Erdbeeren rote Kreise? Genau, du kannst es ja so weit abstrahieren, dass eine Erdbeere am Ende ist nur ein Punkt oder irgendwas. Aber wer sagt, ab wann ist eine grafische Darstellung einer Erdbeere wirklich eine Erdbeere? Und ab wann ist es nicht mehr nur, ja für mich ist es halt das. In der konkreten Situation würde ich aber sagen, wenn auf der Hose
Kreise sind,
und das kleine Mädchen
sagt, ich liebe diese Hose,
da sind Erdbeeren drauf,
bin ich bei der Oma, ihr zu sagen,
wir haben doch jetzt hier keine
Abstraktion verdient,
das kleine Mädchen muss lernen,
rote Kreise sind, rote Kreise sind,
dann bin ich Realist, klar, das kannst du sagen, wenn es für dich Erdbe. Na, ich bin 100% auf der Seite des Mädchens. Rote Kreise, dann bin ich Realist.
Klar, das kannst du sagen, wenn es für dich Erdbeeren sind.
Ich will nur kurz anmerken, wenn du hier gerade wirklich Erdbeeren siehst, hast du einen fucking Schaden.
Aber warum?
Es gibt ja so Muster, wo das halt abstrahiert ist.
Das ist dann halt, sagen wir mal, ein roter Kreis mit schwarzen Pünktchen.
Ja, oder oben dann noch so ein grüner Strich, wo man diesen grünen, diesen Stunk. Und da würdest du sagen, sobald dieser Strunk da ist, ab dann darf man sagen, Erdbeere, aber der muss dabei sein, oder was. Weil das ist ja interessant, ab welchem grafischen Element ist es dann genau schon eine Erdbeere und nicht? Aber das finde ich, ja, verstehe ich, aber wenn da rote Kreise auf einer Blue Jeans, wir reden von einer normalen Blue Jeans. Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie da drüber sind. Und dann sind da rote Kreise drauf. Ja. Und sie sagt, ich liebe diese Hose, ich liebe Erdbeeren, ich liebe meine Erdbeerenhose. Ja. Würde ich sagen, cool, also ja, yes and, ich würde sagen, ja, cool, schön, was siehst du denn? Weil vielleicht hat sie, sieht sie schlecht. Aber vor allem, ich denke mir, wem ist denn geholfen mit dieser Korrektur? Nein, das sind nur rote Kreise. Natürlich sieht das Kind nur rote Kreise, aber für sie sind das halt Erdbeeren. Ich bin natürlich komplett bei dir und bin natürlich komplett beim kleinen Mädchen. Ich finde, man sollte die Welt immer spannender machen, als sie ist. Man sollte immer mehr sehen und bin auch kein Fan von diesem Hyperrealismus, dann von dieser Frau. Von diesen neumodischen Hosen mit den perfekt fotorealistischen Erdbeeren drauf. Da sind wir, glaube ich, beide keine Fans. Ich muss jetzt aber auch sagen, dass wir es hier vielleicht einfach mit einer alten Frau zu tun haben, die nicht mehr, hast du gerade das Nicht-Rauchen-Schild vom Bett gestoßen? Ab jetzt kann man rauchen. Okay, endlich. Endlich Paffen, endlich. Muss aber sagen, dass die Oma vielleicht einfach an dem Punkt ist, wo sie Dinge nicht mehr so gut erkennt, wo sie Dinge und sich so ein bisschen beweisen wollte und der Umwelt beweisen wollte, dass sie nicht irre ist, sondern halt sagen will, ja, das sind einfach rote Kreise. Okay, ich verstehe deinen Punkt, aber angenommen, wir schauen jetzt auf die C und A-Seite und da sehen wir die Hose und da steht Hose mit Erdbeermotiv und es sind rote Kreise. Würdest du dann sagen, okay, der Designer hat gesagt, das sind Erdbeeren, dann ist es gültig oder würdest du weiterhin sagen, nein, man muss korrigieren, es sind keine Erdbeeren? Ich bin ja auf der anderen Seite, wie gesagt, ich habe gerade nur for the discussion's sake, ich bin immer der Meinung, man sollte das nicht korrigieren. Wenn sie aber jetzt, wenn die Oma gerade ein Problem hat, sozusagen so eine Wahrnehmungsproblematik hat, Dinge nicht mehr so gut sieht, generell, so vielleicht ab und zu das Gefühl hat, sie nimmt die Welt falsch wahr. Aschenbecher habe ich ... Na, Aschenbecher einfach da in die Tasse da unten. Dann würde ich sagen, gib ihr das. Sie muss auch jetzt nicht mehr mitspielen. Ab einem gewissen Alter muss sie nicht mehr mitspielen. Sag einfach. Ach so, okay, die Oma hat kein Bullshit auf dieses kindische Zeug. Ich finde solche Korrekturen immer spannend. Ich kenne das ja ständig, ne? Beim Podcast werden ja ständig korrigiert und Leute korrigieren Dinge. Ich nie. Viele Dinge frage ich mich, wem helft ihr da so? Also dieses, nein, das sind keine Erdbeeren. Das ist falsch. Und es ist so, welche Art von Hilfe ist das jetzt gerade so? Wem ist hier geholfen? Oder ist es einfach nur, nein, die Welt hat korrekt zu sein, vollkommen egal, was die Individuen eigentlich mit dieser Welt anstellen wollen, die muss so präzise sein, wie sie ist. Also, aber interessant. Eigentlich sind wir da jetzt schon sehr nah, habe ich es leider nicht mit, aber wir sind sehr nah an meiner Philosophie- Abiprüfung. Die du ja sonst eigentlich immer am Körper trägst. Nee, die war immer im Studio. Die war immer im Studio. Und jetzt hätten wir sie mal zitieren können, die Abiprüfung in der Philosophie von Stefan Thietze. Weil da geht es genau darum. Es ist eine reine wahrnehmungsethische Philosophie-Klausur. Und das hat jetzt genau gepasst. Genau so dem Thema gepasst. Aber du weißt leider nicht mehr, was drinsteht und kannst deswegen jetzt nicht zurückgreifen auf dein eigenes Wissen, dass du als Sechste dir recht ... Ich versuche gerade herumzulavieren, um irgendwie noch auf was zu kommen, merke aber, je mehr Zeit ich darauf verwende, dass ich nicht darauf kommen werde. Es ist, da war so ein Text, wo es besprochen werden, aber es ging genau darum, wie nehmen Lotte die Welt wahr, wie viel Empathie kriegt man an den Staat, um zu überlegen, anderem Leben die Welt wahrscheinlich anders war als man selber und woher haben wir Wörter, haben wir die, also angenommen du siehst ein, ähm, ich krieg's glaube ich nicht mehr zusammen, angenommen du siehst du biegst dich gerade in einen Abgrund, wo du nicht mehr rauskommst, ich kenn das, wenn man Dinge so so zu 30 Prozent noch weiß und denkt, ich schaffe das, ich schaffe das. Es ist so ein Loch und du siehst so ein Seil, das einen Meter weit reicht und denkst, das wird schon noch weiter reichen. Ich komme da wieder raus aus dem Loch. Es geht so grob darum, weiss man zuerst, was etwas ist, wenn man das Wort kennt. wenn du weisst, du lernst als Kind das Wort Ball und du weisst, was damit gemeint ist, weisst, was damit gemeint ist und was die Eigenschaften eines Balls sind. Wenn du siehst einen Ball, du denkst in deinem Kopf Ball und ist nicht, also was bedingt sich da? Dass du das Konzept kennst oder sie nimmst du zuerst wahr und kannst du überhaupt Dinge ohne das Konzept zu kennen und die Wörter zu kennen schon als sowas wahrnehmen und das ist natürlich schon spannend und das Kind ist eigentlich total geil, ich liebe das ja kreative kleine Kinder, die sehen rote Kreise und fucking Erdbeeren, super was für eine Ar Ja. Was für eine Arschloch-Oma. Ja, es ist schwierig. Für uns waren damals rote Kreise noch rote Kreise. Ja. Sind für euch alle Erdbeeren und Regenbogen. Wenn, dann eine Kirsche, aber anderes Thema, anderes Thema. Meine Lieblingsgeschichte mit dieser Emotion, die es nur bei einem Stamm gibt irgendwo, wo so ein Emotionsforscher, der wollte die forschen und dann dachte er, okay, Emotionen gibt es ja, Freude, Ekel, Wut, Hass und so und dann meinten die, nee, es gibt auch noch Legget. und der so wie, na Legget und dann erkannte diese Emotionen nicht
und dann haben die diesem
Neuling bei diesem Stamm,
bei dieser Kultur erklärt, was Legget ist,
diese Emotionen nicht und dann haben die diesem Neuling bei diesem Stamm, bei dieser Kultur erklärt, was Legget ist, diese Emotionen. Und dann irgendwann hat er das halt nicht gecheckt, er kannte das halt nicht, konnte das auch nicht spüren, aber dann hat er länger mit denen zusammen gelebt und es gelernt und irgendwann hatte er diese neue Emotion freigeschaltet, Legget. Und dann konnte der das spüren und war in diesem kulturellen Kontext mit diesen Leuten und hat das dann gelebt und gespürt. Und irgendwann ist er wieder zurückgereist zu sich nach Hause und hatte grosse Schwierigkeiten damit, weil er dieses, mit diesem Gefühl nicht klarkommt, er konnte das nicht handhaben. Ich glaube nämlich, deswegen ist der Film Arrival ja auch so genial, Sprachen sind Betriebssysteme, Denkmuster, die ordnen Dinge ein und ordnen deine Gedanken ein.
Und ich glaube, dass wir jetzt zum Beispiel die amerikanische Kultur, dadurch, dass wir gut Englisch sprechen oder unsere Generation ja auch durchs Internet so viel mehr englisch sozialisiert ist oder mit angelsächsischem Kram, viel mehr die Kultur freigeschaltet hat. Viel mehr den Humor checken, viel mehr so Zwischentöne, kulturell raffen und deswegen auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen mehr zusammenwachsen. Wir können jetzt raw doggen. Ich glaube, dass, deswegen bin ich vielleicht naiv, aber ich bin sehr optimistisch, dass die Welt zusammenwächst durchs Internet. Einfach weil alle die gleichen Memes, die gleichen Gags, die gleichen ... Klar ist TikTok wahnsinnig toxisch, I guess. Meine Erfahrung ist, ich lache über weirde Insider-Jokes, die wir, eine Bubble aus den unterschiedlichsten Menschen aus Frankreich, Kanada, Holland, New York, was auch immer, machen den gleichen Witz, remixen den. Ich lache über alle. Und das ist doch irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ich habe das Gefühl, das ist jetzt doch zu Weihnachten, finde ich, ein schöner Gedanke. Wir kommen vielleicht auch durch solche toxischen Kack-Apps wie TikTok vielleicht auch einfach zusammen. Die Frage, dass wir zusammenkommen. Ich merke es bei Dota immer und denke mir so, okay, es sind wildfremde Menschen, die sich hassen und vielleicht nicht doch leben mit Freunden Dota spielen.
Aber da ist doch genau das Gegenbeispiel, da muss es nur einen haben wie dich, der dann sagt, what a rude thing to say. Das ist ja eigentlich gar nichts, das ist ja eigentlich nur eine realistische Antwort, die man normalerweise im Leben sagen würde, angewandt auf dieses komische Feld Dota, wo man niemand sagen würde. und die Reaktion, die du sofort bekommst, ist
now you're right, I'm sorry.
Also unter dieser, vielleicht ist direkt
unter. angewandt auf dieses komische Feld Dota, wo es niemand sagen würde. Und die Reaktion, die du sofort bekommst, ist,
you're right, I'm sorry.
Also unter dieser, vielleicht ist direkt unter,
die nächste Stufe unter diesem toxischen Verhalten,
direkt einfach normales, jeder hat sich lieb.
Man muss es nur abholen, ja, das stimmt schon.
Alles sehr schwammig, subjektiv, aber interessant.
Null empirisch.
Ich mag auch harte Fakten, ich mag Excel-Tabellen,
ich liebe Excel-Tabellen, ich lege sie an, zu den verschiedensten Dingen und es ist soweit. Die Zahlen sind da, meine Damen und Herren, die Zahlen sind da. Der Eimer wurde geschlachtet. So, wir reden von Florentins Kleingeldeimer, der über wie viele Jahre jetzt gewachsen und gedeiht ist. Ich habe zurücküberlegt. Tatsächlich hat dieser Eimer einige Umzüge hinter sich. Und ich erinnere mich frühestens an die Berlin-Zeit. Und ich bin nach Berlin gezogen zum Start der Frank-Elzner-Masterclass im Jahre 2013. Ich bin ein bisschen müde zu erwähnen, dass du Frank-Elzner-Alumni bist. Genau, da habe ich dann die Frank-Elzner-Masterclass abgeschlossen, erfolgreich mit einem Diplom abgeschlossen. Ausgebildeter Moderator für morgen. Nein, ausgebildeter Frank-Elstner-Moderator. Und damit habe ich das auch eine gewisse Summe bekommen in Kleingeld, die ich da abgelegt habe. Ich erinnere mich noch, ich weiss nicht, ob ich wirklich 2013 schon angefangen habe, aber in dieser Zeit. Ich glaube, wir können gut und gerne mit ein bisschen Augenzwinkern, mit ein bisschen Augenflackern, Augenkneifen von zehnneifen von zehn Jahren sprechen. Zehn Jahre lang habe ich mein Kleingeld gesammelt. Und dann bin ich umgezogen von Berlin aus Köln, von Köln nach Hamburg, habe ich diesen Eimer immer mit mir geschleppt, wie dieser große gelbe Baumarkteimer mit Kleingeld immer wieder rein, weil ich mag es nicht, einen dicken Geldbeutel zu haben. Ich habe den in der Gesästtasche und man sitzt da so komisch drauf und es sieht unförmiger Körper und so, deswegen tue ich immer jeden Abend mein Kleingeld in den Eimer raus. Kleiner Modetipp von mir, generell Männer, die Geldklemme. Lasst die Portemonnaies aus den Arschtaschen raus, nicht da reinpacken. Eher in die Seitentaschen? Lieber, viel lieber in die Seitentasche, noch besser in Jackentaschen oder irgendwie, jetzt im Winter haben wir doch alle irgendwo oben Fächer oder so, mega geil, aber Arschtasche unästhetisch. Danke für diesen kleinen Modetipp. Ja, und jetzt war es soweit, ich habe nach meinem letzten Umzug gesagt, das ist doch bescheuert, ich musste das, ich habe es alles in Mr. Max Flaschen abgefüllt, mein Kleingeld, ich musste das irgendwie transportieren, weil es auch irgendwann so schwer war, dass ich es schlicht nicht tragen konnte. Ich bin jetzt nicht auch stark. Deswegen hast du Booster Energy Drink getrunken, um die dann tragen zu können. Genau, dann konnte ich die. Also Mr. Max, Kleingeld Eimer, Booster Energy, alles kommt zusammen und überhaupt, um danach nach Schlaf zu gehen, musst du dich auf den Massagesessel setzen, um dann in Ruhe von der Anstrengung zu erholen. Richtig, genau, zum Glück hat mir Thais geholfen im Umzug, es war alles in Ordnung. Ich hatte pro Dose Booster zwei Minuten Zeit, um zu tragen, dann musste ich wieder nachfüllen. Und jetzt konnte ich es, habe ich es in mehreren Teilen abgegeben. Und zwar, ich wusste immer nicht wohin, weil man kann das nicht mehr bei Sparkassenfilialen zum Beispiel, kommen es nicht mehr abgeben, nervig, gibt immer weniger, Bundeszentralbank, wo ist die,
keine Ahnung, wie komme ich da hin mit meinem Zeug,
wie soll ich es transportieren, weiss ich. Zoll,
wüsst du nicht. Zoll, wohin, so,
was ist, wenn ich da umkippe und dann ist es alles
auf der Strasse, hau, hau, dann gehört es allgemein gut.
So, das ist ein Problem, Tauben,
Meisen, Spatzen, Lieben, Geld,
alles Problem. Und deswegen
habe ich jetzt bei einem Supermarkt
in der Nähe von mir, habe ich gesehen, dass die so einen Kleingeldautomaten haben und da habe ich jetzt leider, weil mein Traum war ja immer, der gesamten Kleingeld einmal auf einen Schlag abzugeben. I have a dream, hast du gesagt. Richtig. I have a dream. Von einem Zettel, von einem Bon, wo alles draufsteht. Wie viele Ein-Cent-Münzen, wie viele Zwein-Cent-Münzen, ich wollte alles. Habe aber jetzt realistischerweise gemerkt, dass das nicht geht und ich habe jetzt über mehrere Male, ich habe eine Woche immer eingekauft und habe jeden Tag dann irgendwie ein Fünftel, Siebtel von diesem ganzen Geldschatz mitgenommen. Aber ich habe gesagt, ich fasse das alles in einer Exel... 14? Und dann habe ich all das aber in Excel-Tabelle eingetragen
und ich werde mir jetzt auch,
weil ich habe alle Bonds fotografiert
und ich werde jetzt mit Photoshop
mir einen Bon anfertigen,
wo alles nochmal draufsteht.
Und den werde ich mir aufhängen als Bon,
der sozusagen Fake ist,
aber alles zusammenfasst.
Dafür habe ich mir alles in der Excel-Tabelle zusammengesammelt.
Alles zusammengesammelt. Ich habe ja damals, als ich dir davon erzählt habe, dass jetzt die Schlachtzeit beginnt, der einmal fällig ist, habe ich ja gesagt, Stefan, was glaubst du denn, welche Münzart hat am Ende den meisten Wert geliefert? Ja, da habe ich noch lange drüber nachgedacht. Viel schlaflose Nächte, ich habe gegrübelt und saß am Schreibtisch mit so einem alten Taschenrechner.
So, die Aufnahme hat kurz abgebrochen.
Es ist alles schief gegangen.
Es war ein paar Sekunden, wo das Universum zerbrochen ist.
Ich blute an der Nase und bei Floritin ist die Aufnahme abgebrochen, weil ich bin so aufgeregt jetzt auch.
Stefan war so aufgeregt, jetzt endlich diese Ergebnisse des Geldeimers zu hören.
Excel-Tabellen erregen mich auf eine Art, die nichts anderes schafft, und deswegen blute ich jetzt an der Nase. Du hast es bluten, wir kommen einfach aus dem Nichts. Ja, es blutet neben der Nase, das macht es aber eher weirder. Okay. Ich, genau, also ich war dabei zu erklären, wie meine Rechnung kommt. Inzwischen denke ich mir, vielleicht sind 20-Cent-Münzen. Also, welche Münzart ist die wertvollste? Welche Münzart hat am meisten Wert generiert am Ende des Tages? Ich habe letztes Mal, da haben wir in Hamburg aufgenommen, da habe ich gesagt, die 20-Cent-Münze. Inzwischen würde ich sagen, die 50-Cent-Münze, weil auch da natürlich, wenn es weniger sind, am Ende ist es trotzdem fast ... Mehr als doppelt so viel Wert. Ja, wirhe-Modus, wir rechnen alles aus, Anteile ist alles geil. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind noch nicht richtig im Mathe-Modus, aber wir reden im Mathe-Modus. Also, ich kann ja mal zusammenfassen, ich habe alles in der Excel-Tabelle zusammen getragen. Also, mal ganz kurz ein paar Fun-Facts am Anfang, ein paar Randnotizen. Und zwar, der durchschnittliche Münzwert, also wenn man alle Münzen nimmt und den durchschnittlichen Wert berechnet, liegt bei 12 Cent. 12 Cent durchschnittlicher Münzwert. Genau. Jetzt darf man aber nicht vergessen, dass man ja mit 1 Cent und 2 Cent da unten recht viel hat. 1 Cent, 2 Cent, dann kommen 5 Cent und dann oben werden die Abstände grösser. Dann würde ich sagen, zwei Cent hast du ja fast, zwei Euro hast du ja fast gar nicht, ein Euro wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Das ist immer so die Frage, wie viel, ach ja, schwer zu sagen. Also zwölf Cent der durchschnittliche Münzwert, insgesamt kann ich ja mal sagen, 37 Kilo. 37 Kilo wiegt das Ganze, berechnet. Ich habe mir extra bei der Bundesbank die Gewichte der einzelnen Münzen rausgesucht. Später müssen wir sagen, wie viel Geld ein Kilo wert ist, so Kleingeld. Oh, okay, das können wir auch, das ist gut, das ist nicht schlecht. Das können wir dann gut für jeden an die Hand geben. 37 Kilo waren es insgesamt. So, wir fangen mal an. Und zwar, was war die häufigste Münze? Welche Münze gab es am meisten in meinem Eimer? Zwei Cent. Zwei Cent ist vollkommen korrekt. Das ergibt auch genau Sinn. Zwei Cent hat insgesamt für 43 Euro gesorgt. Es waren 2.190 Münzen. Aber jetzt würde ich sagen, 20 Cent ist die häufigste Münze, weil nicht die häufigste, die häufigste ist 2 Cent, weil diese 1, 2, 5 Information, die wir jetzt haben, wo du gesagt hast, also wir haben ja quasi 1, 2, 5 und dann haben wir nochmal 1, 2, 5, nämlich mit 10, 20, 50. Weißt du, wir haben die gleichen Abstände, Einmal in Kupfer, einmal in, was ist das, Messing. Ja, okay, ja. Ja, pass auf, aber ... Gold. Pures Gold. Ja. Und jetzt glaube ich, dass 20 Cent verhältnismäßig viel vorkommt, weil die 2 Cent-Münze so häufig vorkommt. Ja, dir ist schon klar, du verlierst Blut gerade. Also du musst natürlich auch das mit das mit in Erwägung ziehen. Also 2000, zwei Cent Münzen für 40 Euro. 40 Euro. Ich war so stocksauer am Automaten, weil ich immer gesehen habe, wie viel da runterklimpert und wie da nichts geht am Wert einfach, weil ich 40 Euro für 2000 Münzen. 2000. So, aber das heißt für mich jetzt, man kann das einfach wegwerfen. Zwei S Cent kannst du, ja, kannst du komplett wegwerfen. Mit einem Gesamtgewicht von 6,7 Kilo, 40 Euro am Ende, zwei Cent. Die seltenste Münze war das zwei Euro Stück mit 21 Exemplaren. Das hat man nämlich nicht, damit bezahlst du nämlich deine Lieferandoleute, wie gesagt. Ja, immer als Trinkgeld brauchst du, äh, 42 Euro dementsprechend bei 21 Münzen. Genauso viel. Ja, genau so viel, genau, 40 Euro, zwei Cent, eines zweitausend Münzen, das andere zwei. Es ist einfach, es ist einfach geil, es ist einfach geil. Okay, kommen wir zu der großen Frage, welche Münzart ist die, die am meisten Wert bringt? Und zwar hat sie für 30 Prozent des Gesamtwerts gesorgt. 30 Prozent des Gesamtwerts des Eimers hat eine einzige Münzart generiert. Mein Gesamtwert übrigens, würde ich behaupten, ist, habe ich schon gesagt, 2200 Euro sowas.
Okay, für den Gesamtwert kommen wir noch dazu.
30 Prozent wurden bei, es gibt ja wie viele, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht verschiedene Münzen.
Trotzdem hat eine Münze für 30 Prozent des Werts gesorgt, damit am meisten, damit die wertvollste Münze, es waren die 20 Cent. Es waren die 20 Cent mit 1660 Exemplaren für 333 Euro. Gesamtwert nicht so hoch wie ich das. 600 Exemplaren, ich kann es ja direkt sagen, die Füchse im Hintergrund rechnen jetzt schon rum. Es ist ein Gesamtwert von 1.103,71 Euro bei 9.095 Münzen. 1.103 Euro bei 71 Cent. Ja, das ist mein Werk nach zehn Jahren. Also jedes Jahr circa 100 Euro. Ja, es ist wirklich krass, was da zusammenkommt. Ich denke natürlich, klar, ich denke natürlich, Zins, Zins, Zins. Hätte ich das vor zehn Jahren investiert, welche Beträge ständen dann hier, wenn ich das, wenn ich jede Münze ... Nochmal, Entschuldigung, ich wollte nicht schon wieder das Mikrofon ins Gesicht dotzen, tut mir leid. Das heißt, wenn man das alles investiert hätte, jedes Jahr die 100 Euro, was hätte man da alles schaffen können? Unfassbar. Aber genau, und Inflation. Und Inflation, ja, völlig richtig. Und das scheiß Automat hat ja auch noch Gebühren. Ah ja, wurde das schon abgezogen drüber reden. Wurde der abgezogen? Wurde der schon abgezogen?
Nein, das sind jetzt wirklich einfach nur der Münzwert berechnet an Wert. Dann rechne mal kurz diese 1103,71 Euro durch wie viel 37 Kilo? Ich liebe Excel-Tabellen. Also du willst wissen, was willst du wissen, wie viel Geld ist ein Kilo wert? Genau, Wie gesagt, 1103,71 Euro durch Kilogramm, Gesamtkilogramm Anzahl. Ein Kilo sind neunundzwanzig Euro. Ja. Ja, sind neunundzwanzig mal siebendreißig denn eintausend einhundert? Ja. Ja. Ja, also wenn's also klingt das nicht grob falsch. Dann würde ich sagen, ja. Okay, ein Kilo Kleingeld ist 29 Euro wert. Warte, tausend? Tausend durchsinnig? Aber es kommt schon drauf an, welcher Kilo. Weißt du, was ich meine? Wenn du einmal so in die Hand reingreifst und dann erwischst du halt die ganzen Ein-Cent-Münzen, dann ist das ein Kilo weniger wert. Also das ist natürlich jetzt meine spezielle Verteilung. Aber deine spezielle Verteilung ist ja, da bist du ja glaube ich die Norm. Ich glaube schon, dass ich relativ nah an der Norm dran bin, ja. Also das muss man schon sagen. Was für mich auch spannend war, ich bin ja auch neben Mathematik ein Riesenfan von Tektonik. Und das war ganz spannend für mich zu sehen, weil dieser Eimer, der stand ja über zehn Jahre da. Das ist so langweilig. Und weil ich habe dann nämlich den von oben abgeschöpft.
Aha, welche Münzen sind wo?
Und ich habe gemerkt, dass die Verteilung der verschiedenen Abgaben, es gab ja mehrere Abgaben, Stück für Stück, und die Verteilung war stark unterschiedlich. Bist du von oben nach unten? Ich bin von oben nach unten und ich hatte sehr unterschiedliche Durchschnittswerte von den Münzen. Ich hatte zum Beispiel einen Durchgang, wo extrem viele kleine Münzen drin waren.
War das unten oder oben?
Das ist natürlich schwer zu rekonstruieren,
aber das war tatsächlich
die
Boah, denn Excel-Tabelle ist wirklich
riesig, ist ja lustig. Die zweite
Abgabe hat ungefähr
genauso viel Münzen wie die anderen,
aber nur die Hälfte des Werts.
Das heißt, ich weiß aber auch nicht, es kann sein, dass ich die, die unten waren, als erstes abgegeben habe. Tektonisch, aber was ich sagen möchte, es gab Unterschiede. Was du sagen kannst jetzt ist, entweder waren oben oder unten die Kleinen. Genau. Das ist so dumm, dass du das nicht nachgehalten hast. Ja, weil ich habe mir nicht gemerkt, in welcher Reihenfolge ich die jetzt abgefüllt habe, diese Flaschen. Aber es ist genau, was du gesagt habe, entweder sind die Kleinen oben oder unten. Also nicht hingewiesen. Ja, die Kleinen werden ja wahrscheinlich unten sein, oder nicht? Oder oben? Ja, weil sie leicht sind, oder was? Ja, keine Ahnung, weil die schweren. Nee, weil die runterrieseln. Kleine Dinge sind eher unten, oder? Ja, we don't know. Bei einer Tüte Chips hast du doch die Kleinen unten, die grossen oben. We don't know. Da sind doch die Tektonic Basics, die ich nicht mit jeder Beobachtung neu beweisen muss. Also das ist jetzt wirklich lächerlich. So, aber das ist mir aufgefallen, das ist ganz spannend, das heißt, falls ihr abgebt und merkt, oh, das ist aber miese Ausbeute, nicht verzagen, es kann sein, dass ihr bei eurem Eimer, falls ihr es genauso macht wie ich, mit mehreren Abgaben, möchte ich nur meine Erfahrungen sein. Und die zwischendurch umfüllt in Mr. Max Flaschen, wo dann
Tektonik gar keine
Rolle mehr spielt. So, und da möchte ich euch
nämlich dazu anhalten,
nicht verzagen, es können bessere
Tage auf euch zukommen, denn Tektonik
spielt tatsächlich eine Rolle,
es finden sich unterschiedliche Schichten
ein, tatsächlich, ja. Aber es ist
natürlich auch interessant, jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich, weil ich
hab oft diesen Eimer auch durchgraben, weil ich natürlich oft die Situation hatte, ich bestelle Essen und dann, oh fuck, der kommt gleich, ich habe keinen Trinkgeld, dann grabe ich, um noch irgendwo ein zwei Euro Stück rauszukramen, irgendwo muss noch eins sein. Aber das ist ja gegen deine Tektonik-These gerade. Ja, aber das ist dann einmal. Die Tee-Tee. Nee, dann, es muss ja durchgegraben werden, damit was verändert werden kann, ansonsten wäre ja nur die Struktur beibehalten. Aber in dem Moment, in dem du es durchmischt, dann können die Kleinen nach unten abtragen. Und ich fand es spannend, dass ich immer noch 21, zwei Euro Stücke im Eimer hatte, obwohl ich mich an viele Situationen erinnere, wo ich wirklich minutenlang gewühlt habe und ich nichts gefunden habe, wahrscheinlich meine Hände komplett verseucht habe mit allen Bakterien der Welt, habe ich dann auch gewaschen. Da sind mal so Pestpartikel drin. Pestpartikel, da sind auch noch irgendwie uralte Sachen drin, irgendwie Covid-9 oder so ist da noch drin und sowas und dann tatsächlich immer noch zwei Euro gefunden habe. Also man findet dann immer noch doch was. Wahnsinn, aber 40 Euro nur, genauso viel wie die ganze Zeit. 40 Euro durch zwei Euro Stücke, ja, absolut. Wahnsinn, nicht so viel Geld, wie ich dachte. Ja, ich war auch ein kleines bisschen enttäuscht, muss ich sagen, aber am Ende waren wirklich sehr, sehr viele kleine Münzen. Es ist schon wahnsinnig viel Geld, für Kleingeld, klar. Ja. Aber es waren noch 37 Kilo, what the fuck? 37 Kilo, ja. Ein Kilo macht also aus 29 Euro. Diese 1-5-Cent-Münzen sind wirklich die absolute Katastrophe. Wollen wir die nicht einfach killen? Die braucht kein Mensch. Wir sparen uns doch so viele Kosten, die zu prägen und so ein Schwachsinn. Das sind über 5000 Münzen, also mehr als die Hälfte der Münzen waren 1-, 2- und 5-Cent-Münzen und die haben wirklich insgesamt haben die 12% des Werts generiert. Bei, also über die Hälfte der Münzen haben nur zwölf Prozent des Werts generiert. Also absolute Katastrophe, diese drei Dinge sind. Ich habe sogar letztens, glaube ich, hieß es da nicht, weil jetzt in den USA gibt es jetzt dieses Efficiency Ministry mit Musk, der jetzt alles effizient machen soll. Und da war so ein Tweet, wo ihm jemand gesagt hat, schafft die Eins-Händ-Münze ab. Und ich bin kein Fan von Musk und seiner Politik, aber ich dachte mir, ja, mach mal. Also das sind jetzt genau die Leute, die sagen, wir machen es einfach mal. Was ich nicht verstehe ist ... Und als Präzedenzfall. Einfach mal gucken, wenn die untergehen und so, gut, dann ist halt USA weg. Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum man sich bei Währung auf Nachkommastellen verständigt hat.
Irgendwo musst du die Grenze machen. Irgendwas ist dann noch einen Cent und irgendwas nicht mehr.
Irgendwo machst du diese Grenze. Man kann sie einfach bei vollen Eurozahlen machen.
Es braucht keine Nachkommastellen.
Na gut, aber dann kostet die eine Capri Sun für einen Euro oder was, das geht ja auch nicht.
Die Capri Sun muss ja weniger kosten als einen Euro. Nee, macht die einen Euro. Oder dein Kaugummi. Wie alles kostet einen Euro. Du kannst doch nicht sagen, Chuba Chubs lutscht für einen Euro und dann sagst du, wir erhöhen jetzt den Preis. Nee, das ist ein halber Euro. Okay, alles klar. Gute Ideen, wirklich, tweete mal an Musk, ich glaube, da hast du gute Ideen. Du gibst einen Euro, also du weißt alles. Ja, du hast im Hinterkopf so, das ist nicht ein ganzer Euro. Der Rewe-Typ sagt dann so, ja, komm, gib mir mal einen Euro. Ich weiß nicht, ob man ein Finanzsystem darauf aufbauen kann, aber was wir machen könnten zum Beispiel ist, warte mal, wir nehmen uns alle, ich finde die Idee gut, wir nehmen alle Produkte, die zwischen null und ein Euro kosten und alle Produkte, die zwischen ein und zwei Euro kosten.
Und jetzt verschieben wir einfach nur die Kosten. Also sagen wir jetzt mal, eine Mannerwaffel kostet 1,50 und ein Chubber-Chubbs-Lutscher kostet 50 Cent. Dann nehmen wir die 50 Cent von der Mannerwaffel, geben sie dem Chubber-Chubbs-Lutscher, beide kostet einen Euro, und solange die Leute noch im gleichen Verhältnis Mannerwaffeln und Chubber-Chubs kaufen, dann ist alles ausgeglichen. Das muss sich für jeden ausgleichen. Deswegen sind das wie Butter und Milch. Mach eins halt wahnsinnig billig, in eins halt wahnsinnig teuer, dann gleicht es sich irgendwie aus. Man kauft aber eh immer beides, also ist es egal. Genau, sowas, bei Eiern oder so, oder was auch immer. Aber genau, das kriegen wir doch hin. Ich will nur, wir können Wir können auch meinetwegen, hey, ich bin ja gar nicht so, wir lassen die 50 Cent da noch, aber Rest weg. Zumindest braucht man diese Kupferscheisse nicht mehr. Deine Excel-Tabelle sagt mir Kupfergeld. Das Kupfer weg, ne? Also, ja klar. Wir sind am Ende die Leidtragenden, Sparschweine, ne, irgendwie so Kleingeldeimer, musste mal gucken, was die
Kleingeldindustrie wirklich ist, ne, also diese
ähm, stimmt so, ne, also
Trinkgeld und so, unterschätzt das mal nicht, unterschätzt mir das mal nicht, dass dann irgendwie am Ende dann immer diese ganzen Stimmtso Sachen. Immer mit Karte, stimmt so. Ja, aber du bist die Minderheit, du bist die Minderheit. Wenn du dann irgendwie sagst, so stimmt so, Trinkgeld oder sowas in der Richtung, da wird vielleicht viel generiert.
Ich sag Trinkgeld, ich sag stimmtso, das sind meine zwei Argumente. Wer sagt denn, dass zwei Argumente nicht reichen für was? Aber es ist dringend um ein Trinkgeld, ein Argument, weil Stimmbso ist gleich Trinkgeld. Du sagst immer, die Anzahl der Argumente ist so wichtig. Nein, ein gutes Argument reicht. Zwei Argumente reichen völlig aus. Und hast aber keine zwei. Und wenn du sagst, stimmt so, oder wenn du Trinkgeld gibst. Es ist beides das Gleiche. Ein Argument, ein wichtiges Argument, genau wie Leute, die in der Fußgabe sind. Nein, Trinkgeld ist was anderes. Stimmt so ist, wenn du aufrundest auf einen gewissen Betrag. Um demjenigen was zu geben. Nein, ich sage Folgendes. Stimmt so ist, damit du weniger Stress hast mit dem Kleingeldscheiß. Trinkgeld gibst du als Wertschätzung dem anderen. Ich kann aber Trinkgeld auch geben mit dem reinen Stimmt so. Ja, du kannst Trinkgeld geben mit Stimmt so. Aber wenn du an der Kasse sagst, ja ... Jedes Trinkgeld ist auch ein Stimmt so, aber nicht jedes Stimmt so ist auch Trinkgeld. Manchmal ist ein Stimmt so auch einfach eine Vereinfachung. Richtig, genau. Stimmt so, du gibst ja an der Kasse kein Trinkgeld, wenn du sagst Stimmt so. Ja, das ist auch Trinkgeld. Manchmal ist ein Stimm-So auch einfach eine Vereinfachung. Richtig, genau. Stimm-So, du gibst ja an der Kasse kein Trinkgeld, wenn du sagst Stimm-So. Ja. Das ist kein Trinkgeld. Ich. Ah, ah, zwei Argumente. Waren zwei Argumente. Cool. So. Wie viele hast du denn? Ich finde, du hast schon noch den Punkt. Ich möchte nur sagen, Excel-Tabellen sind toll, Excel-Tabellen machen das Leben besser. Ja. Und das Leben ist wahnsinnig komplex, macht uns allen Angst. Existenz, schwierige Frage. Aber Excel-Tabellen und Mathematik machen das ganz einfacher. Beispiel, legt einfach häufiger mal eine Excel-Tabelle an, denn ein Beispiel aus meinem Leben, ich habe meine Bahncard ausgerechnet. Welche Bahncard brauche ich? Weil irgendwann dachte ich, ich fahre doch jetzt mehr Zug. Und dann habe ich, weil alle mal sagen, Kurvendiskussion, was man in der Mathematik lernt, bla bla bla, brauchen niemand mehr, was für ein Quatsch, was lernen unsere Kinder in der Schule? Nee, man kann es einfach auch einfach anwenden, weil dann habe ich so Gleichungen aufgeschrieben für wie viele Bahnkarten, wie viele Bahnfahrten ich habe im Jahr. Wie viele Bahnkarten.
Wenn ich jeden Monat eine Bahnkarte brauche.
Und genau, wie dumm macht mich das.
Und dann durchschnittlicher Preis.
Und man kommt sehr schnell auf zwei Kurven.
Und der Schnittpunkt ist genau die Anzahl Bahnfahrten, die ich brauche, damit sich eine Bahnkarte 50 lohnt. Ja Ja, da kriegst du überarbeitet. Habe ich überschritten, also Bahncard 50 ist für mich die optimale Karte. Super. Wenn ich, und das ist sehr schnell auch im Kopf auszurechnen, du brauchst auch dringend genommen keine Excel-Tabelle dafür, aber du hast dann visualisiert. Du siehst dann genau, ah, bei so und so viel Bahnfahrten bräuchte ich eine Bahncard, 100 sogar. Krass. Und jetzt frage ich mich, sollte die Bahn diesen Rechner anbieten auf der Website oder würden die sich ins eigene Gleis schießen damit, wenn die Leute checken würden, was es genau bringt? Das frage ich mich immer. Welche Produkte würden mehr gekauft werden, wenn Leute mehr Informationen hätten? Und welche Produkte würden weniger gekauft werden, wenn Leute mehr Informationen hätten? Also welche Firmen wollen, dass die Leute mehr über ihr Produkt wissen und welche wollen es genau nicht? Du siehst es genau an der Anzahl der allen Leuten, die Werbung machen, alle Firmen, die Werbung machen, siehst du es. Mehr Informationen, Gleichworte machen das. Aber Werbung ist ja nicht Information. Werbung kann ja auch Lifestyle, Gefühle und sowas sein. Aber wenn die Bahn jetzt sagt, hey, wir bieten den Rechner an, gibt die, also wir analysieren automatisch, wie viel bist du letztes Jahr Bahn gefahren und wir sagen dir, hätte sich eine Bahncard gelohnt oder nicht. Ich glaube, die Bahn würde verlieren. Ja, glaube ich auch. Weil Leute Bahncards kaufen, weil sie Spahnfüchse sein wollen, aber dann merken sie, was es für ein absoluter Abgrund ist, Bahn zu fahren und dann fahren sie es nicht mehr. Nee, ich glaub, Bahn-, Leute haben Angst vor Abos, Leute wollen keine Bahncard, würden aber recht schnell sparen. Ach so rum, man kann auch sein. Die wollen gar nicht, dass man sich eine Bahncard kauft. Wollen wir so einen Rechner anbieten? Einfach mal eine neue Webseite? Eine neue Webseite? Wir haben eine neue Webseite? Ah ja, genau, das wollte ich auch noch erzählen. Ich habe mich nämlich hingesetzt ... Du hast hier reingefuchst. Reingefuchst, habe richtig Spaß daran bekommen. Und jetzt haben wir eine neue Webseite. Also Vorsicht, Stefan ist kein professioneller Webentwickler. Es kann sein, dass ihr euch da wirklich Pestikola reinfällt. Also ich würde da jetzt an eurer Stelle nicht irgendwie ohne VPN draufgehen. Ja, nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich würde auch jetzt an eurer Stelle nicht unbedingt da dieses Kontaktformular nutzen, weil dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass eure E-Mail-Adresse überall ist. Ich bin ja kein Profi, auch wenn die Website so aussieht. Aber Aussehen ist dann auch nicht alles. Für mich ist Aussehen alles, die Funktionalität. Ja, aber das Backend ist verrostet, Spaghetti. Kein Link führt dahin, wo er soll. Wenn er irgendwo draufklickt, ist es gut möglich, dass er auf irgendeiner Pornoseite oder sowas landet. Da, wie gesagt, keine ... Aber es ist ja zumindest schön, und die Fassade, es ist wie so ein Studio, wie so ein Babelsberg, wo so eine Strasse steht, wo dann schön ist, wenn du an einer Tür aufgehst, merkst du, ah, es hat keine Tür, es ist einfach ein Brett. Das ist die Website, die sieht gut aus. Ne, man kann die schon benutzen. Aber wir haben eine neue Adresse, eine Domain auch, eine neue Adresse. Wir haben auch noch podcast-ufo.fail, es musste dann nur plötzlich sehr schnell gehen. Ja, klar. Zum einen, weil ich das dann ungeduldig wurde, zum anderen, weil wir unser Merge gelauncht haben. Richtig, den gibt es immer noch übrigens. Genau, und da, ich bin immer noch für podcast-ufo.fail, aber wir erreichen es auch auf das podcast-ufo.com. Ah, ha. Die E-Mail-Adresse bleibt weiterhin zentrale at podcast-ufo.fail, das ist die Zentrale, die ist wichtig, aber wenn ihr das Kontaktformular nutzt auf unserer Website, das podcast-ufo.com, erreicht ihr auch die Zentrale weiter. Ihr werdet umgeleitet. Ich hatte die Aufgabe, dann die Umleitung zu machen und ich habe gemerkt, dass mittlerweile wirklich etliche Domains auf podcast-uvo.fail umleiten und die leitet jetzt nochmal um auf eine andere. Also man kann, wenn man so eine Domain hat, kann man angeben, wer diese Website besucht, soll umgeleitet werden auf eine andere. Und ich habe mir dann auch kurz überlegt. Diese Spiegel, die man gegenüberstellt. Genau, damit man da ankommt. Und ich habe mir kurz und das habe ich dann nicht gemacht, weil ich hatte wirklich Angst, dass ich das Internet breche.
Was passiert, wenn ich A auf B umleite,
B auf C umleite und C auf A umleite? Da kommt eine Fehlermeldung gesagt in der Umleitungsschleife. Das geht? Genau, da kommt einfach eine Fehlermeldung. Ich habe mich nicht getraut, das zu machen, weil ich dachte, dann irgendwie wirbeln unsere Hörer hin zum Vortex. Ich will dich jetzt nicht desillusionieren, aber du bist nicht der erste Mensch, auf diese Idee gekommen ist. Alles klar, ja, habe ich mir auch gedacht. Und dann kommt sofort eine Fehlermeldung, das ist eine Umleitungsschleife. Sofort bei der, sobald du die Adresse eingestellt hast? Ja, ja, sofort. Und dein Browser sagt, Vorsicht, ich habe sofort gecheckt. Ja gut, aber wenn du das jetzt über hunderte Demäldern machst, ist dein Browser so schlau? Wahrscheinlich schon. Ich glaube, im Kern ist das das Internet. Ich glaube schon, dass Leute sich da gedanken. Das ist das Universum. Das Universum ist ein grosser Kreis. Dinge leiten ineinander über. Wir sind nur noch nicht einmal durch. Ah, okay. Aber wir wissen nicht, dass wir in so einer Schleife sind. Vielleicht ist der Tod der Moment, wo man merkt, dass sich alles wiederholt. Alles wiederholt sich. Und dann bist du wieder klein. Alles ist ein Kreis. Wir sind in einer Riesenumleitungsschleife. Dinge führen zu Dingen, die führen zu Dingen und die führen dann letztlich wieder zum Anfang. Everything is connected. So, jetzt habe ich eine Filmidee. Und zwar die Welt als Welt. Also die Welt an sich. Niemand hat an eine andere Welt gedacht. Warte, die Welt kriegt eine Fehlermeldung. So, es poppt einfach über irgendein Feld in Arkansas, poppt eine Fehlermeldung auf. Connection Error. Einfach so, oder esc Error oder irgendwie sowas. Sync Error. So, bam! Und niemand weiß, was los ist. Und dann alle kommen da so Forscher und so, das ist eine ähnliche Arrival. Die bauen dann so eine Militärbasis auf und so und überall, genau, überall auf. Wir schneiden, okay, pass auf, wir müssen hier gar kein Geld, wir schneiden einfach nur Arrival um, aber anstatt Raumschiffen. Eigentlich reicht einfach so ein bisschen VFX-Aufwand. Alle Raumschiffe machen wir zu dieser Fehlermeldung, die da aufploppt. Und der Rest ist eigentlich gleich. Und ab und zu wird dann Amy Adams übersprochen mit Fehlermeldung. Genau, wir sehen erst mal Fehlermeldung ist erschienen. Ja, wir sehen erst mal so einen nein, Fehlermeldung, ist erschienen.
Ja, wir sehen erst mal so einen Farmer, Arkansas,
der ist irgendwie mit seiner Sense oder mit seiner Maschine oder so,
fährt da durch und plötzlich vor ihm ...
Fehlermeldung.
Sense sagt andere Zeit.
Nein, nein, nein, aktuelle Zeit, keine Sorge.
Der ist mit seinem GPS-gesteuerten Traktorsystem unterwegs.
Super, danke.
Plötzlich vor ihm, er merkt auf seinem GPS so, Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, piep piep, und er wird so, ah, those fucking rabbits, und er holt seine Shotgun, gonna show them who's the boss, und dann schaut er so raus und, oh, ist gar kein Rabbit, sondern eine Fehlermeldung. Die im Himmel erschienen ist? Die schwebt, so sagen wir mal, so ein Meter zwanzig über der Erde. Hovert die so? Hovert die so. Was macht die mal bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla What is this bullshit? Und dann geht er hin und die hat nämlich rechts... Eine Sache möchte ich sagen, den Arkansas Accent nails du par excellence. Und dann hat die, die Fehlermeldung hat nämlich rechts oben so ein X. Und dann geht er hin so, I'm gonna get rid of that bullshit. Und dann drückt er so auf das X. Kann er erst mal draufschießen, bitte? Oh ja, ja, genau. Erst mal schießt er drauf. Gonna get some light, boy. Und dann erst mal Shotgun und wir sehen so, wie das so durch die, durch, und es schliesst sich sofort wieder die Löcher, die so geschlagen wurden von dem Schrot. So, und dann, gonna cancel this shit. Und dann geht er hin zu dem X, drückt auf das X und dann wieder, und dann kommt die sozusagen wieder. San Francisco Uni. Ja. Amy Adams hält so eine typische Uniszenen, Vorlesungsszene, wo sie an der Tafel erklärt, ja, was sind, die Welt sind im Prinzip Null und Einsen, alles kann man runterrechnen, alles kann man runterbrechen. Und jetzt Achtung, pass auf, Amy Adams will, okay, und dann kommen wir zum nächsten Slide, Fehlermeldung, auf ihrem Laptop aber, eine normale Fehler. Eine normale Fehler, love it, sie ickst sie einfach weg und sie ist weg. Genau, sie ickst es weg und sagt, gotta get rid of that. Sie guckt nach oben, sieht oben an der Tür steht so ein Mann mit Hut und Trenchcoat und so, guckt sie an und sie double taggt, erkennt ihn offensichtlich, ein Mann aus der Vergangenheit, den kennt sie noch. Das ist eine Behörde. Sie macht aber weiter. Der Mann sieht aber, wie sie die Fehlermeldung wegklickt und nickt so. So im Sinne von, sie ist die Richtige. Okay, wir können das mitdrehen. Lass uns mitnehmen. Wir haben noch zwei Stunden des Feierabend. Wir werden es im Schnitt verlieren. Überall auf der Welt gibt es diese Fehlermeldungen, ploppen auf, Syntax Error, Connection Error. Aber dann will ich diese Szene, die Behörden, FBI, whatever, meldet sich bei Amy Adams, sie sagt nein, nein, nein, irgendwann sagt sie ja, ja, ja, wie Filme so aufgebaut sind. Etwas Triviales, was uns eigentlich nicht interessiert in dem Privatleben passiert, dass sie dann doch Ja sagt. Genau. Sie sagt Ja, erst Denial, dann Acceptance, sie beschreitet die neue Pforte, Akt zwei. Sie kümmert sich um das Problem. Und sie ist so eine Informatikerin oder was? Sie ist Computerexpertin? Genau, Informatikprofessorin, aber vielleicht auch hier sowas wie Philosophie, Wahrnehmungskram. Also vielleicht geht es hier ja wirklich, also ist die Frage, worauf die hinaus wird. Oh, nee, oder sie ist so Machine Learning mässig, so von wegen so, ah, wir haben so, haben Maschinen ein Bewusstsein, ab wann so Phänomena von Bewusstseinsbruchstücken in KI und so gedönst, das ist ihr Ding vielleicht. Und dann fährt sie dahin und merkt, Moment mal, die Idee ist so, ist unsere Welt ein Betriebssystem, ist unsere Welt digital, Matrix spielt so ein bisschen mit rein und ja, Akt zwei ist noch offen. Akt zwei ist offen, Akt drei ist offen, Akt zwei ist Crowdfunding. After Credits Team ist auch noch offen. Es ist alles ein Crowdfunding-Movie, schreibt Ideen rein. Ihr könnt einfach, genau, die Datei ist offen im Internet, ihr könnt einfach selber, oh, das finde ich mal geil. Aber bitte löscht nichts. Weißt du, diese Reddit-Ideen manchmal, dass man einen Pixel hat und jeder kann den Pixel befüllen und so und dann passiert am Ende dann doch toxischer Scheiß, aber die Grunde ist ja cool. Das machen wir mit einem Film. Man lädt sozusagen eine MP4-Datei mit allen Frames hoch und jeder kann sich sozusagen um seinen Frame kümmern. Am Ende soll es aber die Idee ist, am Ende soll es einen Film ergeben. Ach so, aber da muss der Film ja schon stehen, oder? Nee, es ist komplett alles leer. Alles leer, es gibt wie viele Frames hat ein Film? Hey Google, wie viele Frames hat ein Film? Ah ja, ja sowas und dann diese Anzahl ist dann im Netz. Das hat jetzt bei den Leuten zu Hause, haben die eine Antwort bekommen, die der Podcast selber nicht gibt. Finde ich clever. Alexa? Hey Alexa. Hi Alexa. Servus, wie sagt man bei Alexa? Grüezi, je nachdem wo sie. Grüezi, Alexa, wie viele Frames hat ein 90-Minüter? So, diese Anzahl. doch so viele. Doch so wenig. Oder ja, je nachdem. Und dann sind leere Canvases, leere Leinwände. Okay, aber angenommen, ich nehme jetzt Frame Nummer 9000. Ja? Sehe ich den Frame, der vor mir kam? Alles in Echtzeit, alles in Echtzeit. Aber dann male ich ja was komplett anderes, als der Frame vor mir war.
Erstmal ja, irgendwann ...
Dann ist es ja einfach nur so ein Bildergewitter.
Exakt, erst mal ja.
Irgendwann fangen Leute aber an, sich zum Beispiel,
wie so Papa Platte bei Reddit, bei diesem Reddit-Ding ...
Zusammenzuschliessen.
Genau, er hat sich mit einer Gruppe zusammengeschlossen und gesagt,
gut, wir nehmen jetzt die Frames, tausend bis zweitausend, bunkern wir. Ja, das sind vier Sekunden oder was? Ja, erst mal. Und da erzählen wir unsere Geschichte. Ja. Ja, okay. So, und da machen sie dann Pepe the Frog oder so rein. Mhm. Der, weiß ich nicht, auf die ... White Power. Ja, so, ja, whatever. Ja, ja. Aber was soll diese Twitch-Leute so machen? Aber ich meine nur so, am Ende glaube ich schon, dass der Anspruch bei den Leuten ist, wir wollen schon eine kohärente Story erzählen. Wir greifen den Frame von davor auf, alles bildet sich in Echtzeit. Und dann die coolsten Ideen gewinnen so ein bisschen. Aber es gibt bestimmt auch so Algorithmen, die das alles so glätten, oder? Also wenn du zwei Frames hast, die ganz unterschiedlich sind, dass man das so glättet, dass es irgendwie ein bisschen nahtloser ist. Das einfach mal über den Komplettfilm klatschen. Ist nicht die Idee von Frames, dass es 24 sind, dass es für uns eh glatt aussieht? Ja, aber ich meine, du kannst es ja bestimmt noch so ein bisschen angleichen, so korrigieren. Wenn du einmal eine ganz große Katze hast und dann eine kleine und dann wieder eine große, dass du das halt so, dass es nicht so viel Bewegung ist auf dem weil ich hab halt Angst, dass es extrem viel Gewitter und Farben und komplett aber deine Ängste macht mir die Idee kaputt du bist so fucking skeptisch ich fand das mit den Fehlermeldungen gut und jetzt ist daraus irgendwie so ein komplettes stroboskopisches Farbengewitter geworden. Aber erst ab als zwei. Ja, aber gut, aber schau mal, du hast mir selber gesagt, das Wichtigste am Film ist der Ton. Und da hast du ja ein Riesenproblem, weil du hast ja dann dieses Blitzgewitter und was ist mit der Tonspur? Die laden wir hoch und dann andere Leute den Ton machen. Ja, okay. Aber weißt du, bei jeder Idee, die ich habe ... Was hast du aus meiner Idee gemacht? Ich bin hierher gekommen mit einer bescheidenen Idee, mit den Fehlermeldungen. Es führt nirgendwo hin. Matrix habe ich schon besser gesehen, diesen Film. Und bei jeder Idee, die ich habe, sagst du immer, du hast Angst vor Gewitter. Ja, das stimmt. Ich bin ein bisschen einseitig
mit meinem Feedback, das ist richtig.
Ich habe halt Angst, dass ihr zu viele Szenen
filmt und die dann so schnell hintereinander schneidet,
dass man überhaupt nicht mehr hinterher kommt.
Wissen Sie doch schon wieder, macht man diese Bewegung da.
Ja, du bist ja bekannt, auch schnell
zu erzählen. Weiß ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich kenne dich ja nur als
Mensch, ich kenne dich ja nicht als Reputation, als Künstler. Ichiss ja nicht, wie man dich da draußen sieht. Oder kennst du mich nur als Künstler. Ja. Was hast du dir für nächstes Jahr vorgenommen? Was hast du dir für Weihnachten vorgenommen? Ach ja, ich bin jetzt echt hart abgestiegen in Dota, ich bin wieder im Rang runter und würde gern wieder weitermachen, ehrlich gesagt. Weil ich habe mir vorgenommen zu kochen.
Und ich will auch, ich habe jetzt zehn Helden gelernt und auf die will ich mich jetzt nochmal fokussieren.
Ich will ein bisschen in die Counterplace rein, also Counterpicks, ich will Draften besser verstehen und da so ein bisschen teilnehmen und da auch ein bisschen, ich will ein eigenes Turnier organisieren, ist auch ein Ziel von mir, mehr aber auch nicht. Haben Leute Schlachtgesang gewesen für indogenen Völkern? Ja, kann sein. Habe ich dich rausgeholt aus der Dota-Scheiße? Das ist die Notbremse. Kochen will ich auch tatsächlich ein bisschen. Ich habe mir jetzt, ich habe dieses Jahr die Bolognese mal so ein bisschen mir angeguckt. Ganz interessant, das Gericht. Schon gemacht? Schon gemacht, nee, nee, schon einige gemacht. Excel-Tapel angelegt? Ich versuche ja, effizient zu sein. Ich überlege mir mal, wie kann ich mit wenig Aufwand viel erreichen. Und ich denke mir, wenn du die Bolognese gemeistert hast, hast du ja schon wirklich die Hälfte von der Lasagne auch schon. Weil das Ragout ist ja quasi wirklich, finde ich, ein Kernstück der Lasagne. Und wenn du die Bolognese da gute Skillpunkte reinballerst, hast du auch fast schon eine gute Lasagne. Ich will jetzt Weihnachten eine schöne Lasagne backen, erster Weihnachtszeit, zweiter Weihnachtszeit, sowas in der Richtung. Aber hast du nicht dafür sogar für deine Pizza jetzt auch eine Excel-Tabelle angelegt? Pizza habe ich eine Excel-Tabelle angelegt, die automatisch alle Zutaten anpasst, je nachdem wie viele Pizze man haben will. Wahnsinn. Mein Problem ist halt der Ofen, das ist immer so das Ding, weil bei Hobby-Pizza-Beckern ist oft so das Ding, ja der Ofen wird halt nicht heiß genug, die normalen handelsüblichen Öfen sind nicht heiß genug, du brauchst eigentlich einen Steinofen, vielleicht baue ich mir den. Du bist ja jetzt um so, vielleicht kannst du dir ein neues Anwesen, den Westflügel, einen riesigen Ofen bauen. Genau, der Westflügel, der ist natürlich noch so ein bisschen frei. Da kann ich natürlich noch einiges bauen. Einfach in die Mitte so ein Pizzaofen. Genau in die Mitte. Irgendwann einfach so ein Ziegel, aber ich würde den ja gerne selber bauen, auch wenn dann, aber nee, also da ist zwischen dem Pool, der Galerie und dem Museum ist da halt irgendwie noch nicht so richtig Platz. So als verbindendes Element, so ein Pizzaofen in die Mitte. Ja. Ich habe jedenfalls gesagt, dass ich für meine Familie Weihnachten koche und das sind so Dinge, und das habe ich in diesem Jahr über mich gelernt. Streng genommen zu spät, weil es gab davor genug Anzeichen, dass ich so bin. Ich liebe es zu planen und mir Dinge in den Kopf zu setzen und ich mag alles, bis es dann Realität wird. Okay. Also ich habe mich so gefreut, mir so ein Menü zu überlegen, mir vorzustellen. Und dann perrigt diese Weine mit dieser Vorspeise und dann gibt es das. Und alle sagen, wow, Stefan, das hast du gekocht, wie cool, mega schön. So, das ist alles geil. Aber dann sich hinzustellen und das wirklich zu kochen, da merke ich auch, ja, ich kann gar nicht kochen. Und das habe ich dieses Jahr auch, ich habe dann dieses Jahr gross meinen Geburtstag gefeiert und so. Und das, bis alle kamen, war ich so. Also ich mag diese Planungssachen. Ich liebe das zu planen, Einladungen zu gestalten, alles zu machen. Wenn es eine Realität ist, merke ich so, aber ich gehe auch dann, wenn ich auf Partys bin, gehe ich ja dann auch gerne schnell nach Hause. Ja, ja, klar, auf jeden Fall. Wenn ich Gastgeber bin, geht das nicht. Aber das ist, natürlich hat man diesen Gedanken nicht, wenn man das plant. Und da muss ich mir in Zukunft merken, ich muss mir besser im Kopf manifestieren, was das Gefühl ist, wenn es Realität wird. Ich glaube, das beste Szenario wäre doch, du planst alles, sogar du engagierst einen Koch, du engagierst Leute und bist dann selbst gar nicht vor Ort. Gatsby, das ist doch Gatsby. Gatsby hat doch immer diese riesigen Partys gefeiert, an denen er nicht teilgenommen hat. Und dann hat er immer nur dieses riesige Nachtleben und diese ganzen Sachen, den Luxus, aber er war nie Teil davon. Du bist eigentlich the big Tizzi. So, du bist doch eigentlich genau das, dass du die grossen Sachen feierst, du lädst alle ein und, oh, du hast eine Einladung, kriegst du einem Titzelfest und so. Klingt nicht so glamourös. Nee, es klingt recht dirty. Titzelfest. Klingt so ein bisschen Titzelfest. Klingt irgendwie wie so ein Ding, wo so eine Steuerung F-Doku drüber gemacht wird und das dann
abgesagt werden muss. Es klingt wie was, wo Tomatolix
was Tomatolix macht
und dann am Ende mit so verwuschelten Hand ersteht und sagt
boah, das war so wild.
Nie wieder Titzelfest so.
Gut, hat es vielleicht einen anderen Klagen mehr.
Gunnar Krupp war auf dem
Titzelfest und hat Dinge offen gelegt.
Ja, also muss man ja gucken.
Aber das könnte ja auch interessant sein, dass du das alles machst und dann bist du aber selber gar nicht in derselben Stadt, bist woanders. War The Great Gatsby dann in einer anderen Stadt? Nee, der war schon vor Ort. Ich glaube, der war in diesem Herrenhaus und hat so am Fenster dann immer zugeguckt, wie alle gefeiert haben und so. Aber ich verstehe es, ich verstehe es. Es war ja auch immer damals, als ich ein Aquarium wollte. Ich wollte das gestalten, ich wollte mir überlegen, welche Fische mit was und so und dann holt man sich die und dann zeigt man auf die Fische und dann sind sie zu Hause, das Aquarium steht und man denkt, so, dann muss ja auch irgendwie weitergehen. Ja, genau. Das Leben ist kein Stillstand, es geht weiter. Der Weg ist das Ziel, sagt man immer, aber tatsächlich ist diese Aussage eigentlich ziemlich schrecklich, weil es heißt, du kommst nie an deinem Ziel an. Die Leute sagen ja, wie toll ist der Weg, aber du sagst ja, aber der Weg endet ja irgendwann am Ziel und dann habe ich ja nicht mehr den Weg. Der Weg ist auch nicht so geil. Ja, das ist auch das Problem.
Wenn der Weg das Ziel ist, fuck.
Weil der Weg ... Ziel ist, fuck.
Weil der Weg,
wenn ich nach links und rechts gucke,
schön ist das hier nicht.
Richtig, und dass der Weg das Ziel ist,
merkst du auch erst, wenn du am Ziel angekommen bist,
und dann konntest du den Weg gar nicht genießen.
Ich will echt mal wirklich was,
ich will alles auf den Kopf stellen dieses Jahr.
Ich will, dass der Ziel des Ziel ist. Du redest wie Jonathan Mese bei Hotel Matz. Ich will mal wirklich disrupten nächstes Jahr. Ich will mal wirklich neu, wirklich auf einen neuen Horizont zu, dass man wirklich mal neu denkt. Jonathan Mese hat bei Hotel Matz den ganzen Tag gesagt, er will dafür plädieren, dass alle zu Hause Klassif machen. Und das hat er so oft gesagt, alle erst mal zu Hause klar Schiff machen. Es müssen erst mal alle bei sich anfangen zu Hause klar Schiff machen. Und ich fand das so gut tatsächlich. Aber es ist so ein Nonsenssatz. Was soll das denn bedeuten? Ja, es klingt wahnsinnig kindlich, passt ja auch so ein bisschen zu seiner Person und so. Aber im Kern, ja, erst mal zu Hause, das Leben leben, was man leben will, zu Hause, seine Prioritäten klären, Dinge, die einen unwohl fühlen lassen, ein bisschen verstoßen. Ja, aber das wollen doch die Mächtigen, dass du sie in Ruhe lässt und dich in dein Privatleben flüchtest. Nein, du musst da auch auf die Strasse gehen, du musst am Palast rütteln, du musst mal irgendwie die Strasse aufmachen. Was ist da unter uns, was ist in der Kanalisation, was machen die da, das treiben die da unten, was ist da eigentlich in den hohen Türmen drin, was ist da los? Ich kann auch sagen, Trump will, dass Leute am 6. Januar am Palast rütteln, also es geht ja in beide Richtungen. Jetzt hast du mich natürlich mit einer klassischen Uno-Reverse-Card in die Ecke getrieben und ich gebe auf, wollen wir nicht Monopoly spielen, wollen wir nicht lieber einfach nur Geld spielen. Ich habe jetzt 1.100 Euro in Kleingeld hier vor Augen. Ja, was machst du damit? An welcher Organisation willst du die Spenden? Ja, kurz davor, weil ich habe tatsächlich Pest und Flausch, ich mache den großen Weihnachtszirkus, die große Spendenmarathon. Genau, das finde ich klasse, ich finde es super toll. Und es wäre doch toll, wenn du jetzt mal deine Organisation vorstellst, wo du das hinsparen bist. Deswegen war das jetzt,
weil, nee, die Sache ist ja die, ich habe ja
ausgeschrieben, schätzt, wie viel Geld
das ist und wer richtig liegt, der kann entscheiden,
zu welcher Wurde. Genau, es hat niemand, oh Wunder,
richtig gelegen. Es hat eine einzige Person überhaupt
eine Schätzung abgegeben. Du hast auch gar keine Schätzung gelesen.
Deswegen, leider hat das nicht
geklappt, deswegen
ist das jetzt meins. Und damit werde ich jetzt. Aber du machst es die 100-Mese-mäßig zu Hause klar schiff. Du nimmst die 1.100 Euro und machst zu Hause klar schiff. Diese Kleingeldautomaten waren ja im Supermarkt und du kriegst kein Geld, sondern du kriegst einen Pfandbon. Nein. Und dann gehst du mit dem Einkaufen und hast dann mehr Geld auf dem Bon als du einkaufst. Und das ist dann immer so diese ...
Zahlen dir die dann 1.100 Euro aus? Ich hab's ja wie gesagt in Stücken, ich hab's ja irgendwie in fünf Stücken oder so. Zahlen dir die dann 3.100 Euro aus? Die zahlen dir das aus und dann kaufst du halt da irgendwie so deinen Kinderriegel und dann sagen sie so, äh, 35 Cent und du so, äh, Bon und dann diese ... Und wie viele Gebühren? Erstmal, wie viele unnötige Artikel hast du deswegen da gekauft? Ja, jedes Mal eines. Ich hatte einen Kinderriegel, ich hatte einen Kinder-Bounty, dann hatte ich einen Kinder-Karten. Wie ich dich kenne, du willst genauso wenig wie ich den Betriebsauflauf stören. Es wäre dir unangenehm, nur einen Kinderriegel zu kaufen und dann den Bon einzulösen. Du hast es mit einem Einkauf verbunden. Ich habe es mit einem Einkauf verbunden. Und ich habe versucht, so viel zu kaufen, dass ich nichts rauskriege, was schwer ist, weil irgendwann brauchst du nichts mehr.
Und dann hast du unnötig viele Artikel gekauft.
Dann hast du halt so, ja gut, Alufolie, Frischhaltefolie, Mülltüten, Klopapier, wo man denkt, das kann man nie zu viel haben.
Aber selbst damit kommst du nicht auf 200, das ist schon schwer.
Das hat nicht geklappt, aber da habe ich dann immer ausgezahlt bekommen, aber ich habe ja auch viel eingekauft, also viel am Ende dann, aber die Gebühren waren erbärmlich hoch. Genau, eine Frage, wie groß waren die Gebühren? Zehn Prozent. Zehn Prozent? Weißt du noch, als ich mich über die Sparkasse aufgeregt habe, weil die acht Euro genommen haben pro Einzahlung? So, und jetzt möchte ich nicht mit einem negativen Ton rausgehen, aber diese Aktion war das Ende
einer langen verzweifelten Suche nach Möglichkeiten.
Und es war nicht die beste Wahl, aber
ich dachte mir irgendwann, ich habe einfach keinen Bock mehr,
ich muss jetzt hier einen Schlussstrich drunter ziehen,
ich kann das nicht ständig mit mir rumschleppen, jetzt ist Schluss.
So, und ich weiß, ihr werdet mich verdammen,
dass ich da relativ viel Geld
dann als Gebühren auszahlen musste, aber es war
für mich einfach eine Last, die jetzt runter ist
von mir, und ich kann jetzt nochmal neu anfangen, und ich habe das gebraucht, auch in dem Moment meines Lebens, dass ich diese Last einfach von meinen Schultern genommen habe. Und ich weiß, es hat viel gezählt. Ich weiß, es hat so viel gekostet. Und ich hatte so Bauchschmerzen, weil ich habe so viele Kinderbäude gegessen und mir ging es nicht gut. Aber jetzt ist es weg. Jetzt bin ich frei. Und jetzt kann ich frei und entspannt ins Jahr 2025 gehen und ich will davon auch nichts mehr hören. Dieser Eimer ist jetzt ... Der Eimer ist weg. Und du gibst dir viel Mühe, deine Hand auszustrecken, das ist nett. So weit weg. Du sitzt so weit weg.
Es ist jetzt auch vorbei und es ist Ende.
Er hat aber tatsächlich beim Bäcker letztens eine ähnliche Situation.
Der Bäcker meinte, damit sie es schon wissen, die Kasse ist kaputt, sie müssen passend zahlen.
Und ich hatte nur 20 Euro, einen 20-Euro-Schein dabei.
Und da dachte ich mir so, jetzt aber hier Richard.
Jetzt aber Richard, dann nehme ich noch einen Baumkuchen und und noch Bienenstich und zwei von den Brötchen da hinten. Wie viel haben wir gerade? 16? Aha, dann nehme ich noch das und so. Und dann konnte ich schön mal ausgeben. Also so auf den Punkt zahlen ist auch schön. So viel mag ich gar nicht bei einem Bäcker. Bei einem guten Bäcker, klar. Die dann so, keine Ahnung, in Köln gibt es dann die Mehlwerkstatt oder Brot. Zur Weihnachtszeit ein schö schöner, herrlicher Baumkuchen. Bei mir ist nur Kamps und da könnte ich im Leben nicht für 20 Euro einkaufen. Die Quarkbällchen kosten drei Cent. Ja, die sind tatsächlich sehr günstig. Das war tatsächlich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir schon im Jahresrückblicks-Modus sein müssen, müssen wir nicht, können wir auch nächste Woche machen. Bitte. Aber ich kann schon mal meinen Tiefpunkt sagen, und zwar, ich wurde gestoppt. Ich wurde dieses Jahr gestoppt, und zwar von Quarkbällchen. Ich war das gesamte Jahr kein einziges Mal krank, keine Beschwerden körperlichen. Ich hatte dieses Handding mit den Armschienen, mit diesem Karpaltunnel-Ding und so. Das hat uns lange begleitet. Das war schon nervig und so, aber ansonsten war mir nur einmal richtig hart schlecht nach Quarkbällchen. Krass. Und die haben mich richtig komplett ausgenockt, das heißt mein Verlierer des Jahres, Quarkbällchen. Anders als ich, ich war das ganze Jahr krank. Ja, du warst super krank. Du hattest sogar Phasen, wo du verschiedene Krankheiten übereinander gelagert hast. Weiß man dann immer nicht genau. Das war ganz schlimm. Aber ich glaube, ich war lange krank. Und das möchte ich nächstes Jahr, habe ich mir auf die Fahne geschrieben, nächstes Jahr bin ich nicht so oft krank. Okay, das finde ich gut. Finde ich gut. Wir können ja nächste Woche nochmal komplett den Jahresrückblick machen, nochmal alles Revue passieren lassen, jeden Monat nochmal schön durch die Finger rieseln lassen. Und habt ihr noch gespeicherte Tweets von uns? Oder wisst eine Seite, wo ich so archive.org mässig die alten Accounts wieder finden kann? Das finden wir schon. Weil das wäre schon cool für mich, dass wir einen Abgesang, einen Goodbye-Song auf Twitter singen. Das machen wir, das wird schön. Ansonsten freuen wir uns auf ein neues Jahr mit das Podcast-UFO. Und Stefan? Mit das Podcast-UFO-Podcast-Projekt, checkt unser Merch aus. Vielleicht landet das schön was unterm Tannenbaum für eure Liebsten. Oh, mal gucken, ob es noch klappt. Wir würden nichts versprechen, wir können natürlich den Gang der Meere nicht beeinflussen. Nee, genau. Und wenn das Schiff leider wieder auf dem Mariannengrund sieht. Wir haben jetzt extra vom anderen Flecken der Erde bestellt, damit wir nicht wieder am Suez, damit wir nicht wieder, weil mein Leben ist so oft liegt am Geschicke des Suezkanals. Man hat auch keinen Einfluss, ne? Und das ist mir jetzt, ich will nicht mehr abhängig sein vom Suezkanal. Ich bin davon unabhängig, das haben wir mir geschworen, letztes Jahr. Das finde ich gut. Wir haben es durchgezogen. Das hast du durchgezogen, ja. Wenig Abhängigkeit vom Suez. Danke an Steffen für das Intro, vielen, vielen Dank, auch mal rückblickend vielen, vielen Dank an alle, die das ganze Jahr über Intros eingeschickt haben. Wir haben viele, viele tolle Intros bekommen, das freut uns, dass das noch so lange klappt. Stefan wollte es beenden, wir haben es nicht beendet dieses Jahr, weil wir unseren Komite so sehr
lieben, weil wir euch mögen
und weil wir jedes Team und jeden Beitrag genießen.
Ich hab's nur gesagt, weil es inzwischen alle uns
nachmachen. Und deswegen
ganz, ganz lieben Dank
an alle, die das eingeschickt haben. Vielen Dank an Reddit
auch, ihr habt ganz tolle Sachen gepostet, wir lachen laut
über alle Sachen, die dort passieren. Haut rein,
macht's gut, wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Macht's gut, tschüss!